at some point all the children who are
told they can do anything if they just
believe hard enough
turn into adults and for the majority of
them whose hopes and dreams don't come
true
the fall back down to reality is
oftentimes painful
and sometimes lethal like most children
felix had been brought up extremely high
by this idea in the early part of his
life
he was told that he could do anything he
wanted if he just believed and worked
hard enough
that he was the sole driver of his
successes or lack thereof
that he was either going to make it and
achieve greatness and worthiness in the
world
or he was not and in both cases it would
be him who was solely responsible or to
blame
now in his mid-30s having worked a
series of jobs in a variety of
industries
starting in mostly service jobs then
going on to different labor and contract
jobs
and most recently a series of office
jobs felix had felt himself falling
further and further from the heights of
his hopes and dreams
approaching in his view the ground floor
of failures and losers
felix always did his jobs well and with
integrity
but hated just about all of them like
many people
he wanted more than a job as a child and
teen
he formed the deep desire to be famous
which he still had not yet shaken
growing up in a single parent household
with a mother who had to work all the
time just to get by
felix was both in a somewhat
disadvantaged position to become highly
successful and famous
while simultaneously a position that
made it all the more desirable and
important to him
he wanted greatness he wanted personal
ownership and creative distinguishment
he wanted independence and legacy he
wanted love
in the form of wealth and blind public
admiration
but he had yet to find anything close
and his self-worth
inextricably linked with his
achievements or lack thereof
now hung in the balance of his life's
aimlessness he felt as though he was an
oncoming failure
who deserved the title
[Music]
it's not as if felix had not tried he
had tried many things
many different ways however everything
seemed to just lead to dead ends
he was too small and slow for the sports
he pursued in high school
his attempts at rapping and singing went
nowhere and his paintings never sold
the only real surviving dream he had
left was filmmaking
which he had formed as an interest in
the middle of high school and held on to
ever since
however his film projects weren't
getting him anywhere either and he
couldn't afford much equipment
which made it hard to appeal to
freelance clients
financially and realistically college
was also not in the cards for felix
and so he couldn't leverage any of the
opportunities that might have existed
that route either
as he aged out of high school further
and further into early adulthood
and none of his dreams were paying any
of the bills he inevitably had to get a
more stable income
inciting the start of him working more
traditional long-term jobs
during and following this time though
felix continued to pursue his personal
goals in film production around his work
schedule
at around 23 for the first time he saw
the beginning of a real potential path
forming towards this dream
getting hired as an unpaid intern as a
weekend filmer
for a local tv studio it was at this
point that felix planned to double down
on his goals of filmmaking
and getting into the world of hollywood
[Music]
one year later however felix's mother
was diagnosed with breast cancer
fortunately within three years time she
would make a full recovery
but this monkey wrench of unforeseen
financial burden
forced felix to refocus his entire
attention on better paying regular jobs
in order to help support his mother and
younger sister during this time
soon the majority of his own time would
be taken up his free time becoming
mostly dedicated to sleeping and
preparing for work
the occasional off days spent just
trying to enjoy the small amount he had
with friends and family and so
forth even though his mother would go on
to recover
felix would for all intents and purposes
become
caught in this routine of life the
stress of his work increasingly draining
him to the point of almost complete
deflation
he couldn't help but get further and
further into the implications of
everything
and lose almost all remaining motivation
and self-belief
finally hitting the ground floor felix
would continue on through his life from
here
working doing his best and living with
his wife marie
and their dog sammy by his late 30s he
had climbed into slightly better job
positions
making and saving better money and
creating an okay life for himself
but he was bored tired and entirely
unfulfilled by the mindless tedium of it
all
he loathed himself and he loathed
himself for loathing himself
knowing that he had it all right and had
no excuse
it was around this time that he had
begun to more seriously consider the
idea of ending the whole thing
frequently ideating on the notions of
failure and pointlessness
and the particular extreme conclusion
that can sometimes be drawn from such a
line of thought
one day around this time while cleaning
out the gutters on the side of his and
his wife's house
felix clumsily missed his step on one of
the rungs of the ladder
and slipped forward off the side falling
onto the ground where the yard met the
edge of the driveway
fortunately the height was fairly low
and he fell safely enough to catch
himself before landing too awkwardly
with exception to a few mild scrapes on
the left side of his torso and thigh
he was fine a close call perhaps but
nothing more
it did however strike felix as he got
back up and finished the job
he thought to himself about how life was
funny like that how fragile and
malleable it is and can be
in one moment everything is one way and
then in the next
with one small wrong step everything can
change
and tragedy can strike suddenly felix
felt a resurgence of motivation run
through his veins
scheming in his head a plan of action to
getting back into camera work and video
production more seriously
he imagined and plotted a scenario where
he would soon be able to quit his job
and go full time on his own pursuing a
higher promised land of individual
greatness
and success
a few days later while at his office job
felix began to feel a horrible sudden
fever
becoming terribly fatigued and unable to
properly hold himself
up it got so bad so quickly his
co-workers called 9-1-1
at the hospital it was discovered that
felix had mrsa
a flesh-eating staph infection while
diagnosing the situation
it would become evident that the source
was those small scrapes he received from
the fall off the ladder
that minor commonplace injury had in
fact exploded into catastrophe
the infection spreading through his
bloodstream and into other areas of his
body
the doctor informed him his wife and
younger sister
that it wasn't clear if he would survive
and it might be wise to say anything
they might like to say to each other
as soon as possible furthermore the
doctor went on to say that if he did
survive
it wasn't clear if he would ever be able
to walk talk or function properly as
himself again
felix immediately underwent two separate
back-to-back surgeries in hopes of
saving him
and removing and repairing as much
infected damage as possible
despite the high level of uncertainty
and doubt felix would survive
somehow he came out the other side
mostly unscathed in comparison to the
expectations
a stroke of unbelievable luck according
to the doctors and nurses
he was essentially as good as before
with exception to one thing
the infection had gotten into his brain
tissue and subsequently
his optic nerves now and almost
certainly for the rest of his life
he was blind
once felix returned home and had enough
time and space to sufficiently realize
what was happening
he quickly began to sink into the
reality of what he deemed was the final
straw of the tragic drama that was his
life
he realized that he would no longer have
any possible chance in doing much of
anything
especially the one thing he still held
some semblance of hope towards
he of course could not pursue camera
work and filmmaking
blind in fact he couldn't really do his
regular job anymore either
seeing as how it was primarily paperwork
and computer files
felix thought about how horribly and
astonishingly unlucky he was
a failure ruined by the gutters tragic
poetry
he thought
felix essentially called it quits on
life at this point sinking into his
living room couch with no plan to ever
get up
over the course of the following several
months the only thing he could bring
himself to do
was continue to shrivel into the couch
cushions and watch endless marathons of
movies
of course felix could not watch the
movies but he could listen
and that's what he did all the time at
some point early on
he would receive entitlement to social
security disability checks each month
essentially absolving him from having to
work or worry about making money
allowing him all the more easily to just
continue watching endless amounts of
movies
focusing on anything or nothing
eventually he would run through so many
movies
good and bad that he began to just
re-watch his favorites over and over
he watched some of them so many times
that he was nearly able to recite the
entirety of the dialogue's verbatim
while watching despite how strange this
little activity of learning the lines of
movies was
it helped felix keep busy giving him
something to do and focus on
filling his days with purpose and
keeping him from the alternative
it eventually got so concentrated and
important to him
that for several of his favorite movies
he actually tried to learn how to play
along with the music as well
playing the melodies on an old keyboard
he was given from his cousin as a
hand-me-down gift
in elementary school even though he
never really played it much as a child
or any time after
strangely he seemed to pick it up fairly
quickly
able to almost mimic the melody of the
songs in the films with only a small
amount of trial and error
he found that he could almost feel the
music with a certain intuitive clarity
knowing exactly where the sounds were
even though he didn't know what he was
playing
or any of the music theory behind it
over the following months felix would
get better and better
adding more instruments and equipment
into the mix and learning the entire
soundtracks to a number of films
he would soon move on to creating his
own original pieces
playing over scenes that didn't already
have music creating songs based on the
particular emotion and
pacing in different films
one year later with the help of his
story intriguing the director enough to
initially get him in the door
felix got his first real break in life
selling a collection of background score
music to a small production
for a series pilot a year later
the show took off another year after
that
felix began working with other similar
productions creating more original
pieces for small shows
ads short films and the like over the
following decade
felix would find himself evolving
through the ranks of hollywood
astonishingly becoming a world-renowned
famous film score composer
for the first time in his life felix
felt successful
and worthwhile at 58 years old
while promoting the premiere of a
feature film that he composed the
original score for
felix was asked to speak as part of the
film's press conference panel
like he often would at these types of
things he introduced himself
and shared his story he shared how the
unluckiest moment of his life
somehow became one of the luckiest that
in some strange sense
the accident that almost killed him
saved him
make no mistake he always added the loss
of his sight posed a vast array of
miserable consequences
but without it he would have never
discovered his greatness
as he put it and he would have never
been there on that stage
later in the night the conference opened
to a q a with the entire audience
several questions in one audience member
directed one at felix
asking i know this might sound strange
to ask but based on what you said
earlier
do you think as though losing your
vision gave you the ability to make
music like this
and it was sort of almost lucky and if
so what role do you think luck plays in
success
in general felix took a moment and
thought to himself before answering
grunting out loud to signify that he had
to briefly think about it
sort of pressured by the need to say
something he began thinking out loud
you know i know my story can sometimes
come off as
a typical hopes and dreams always come
true kind of thing
that everything always works out but it
isn't
and it doesn't not really people up here
are typically supposed to say those
sorts of things
and people up here seem to often believe
those sorts of things
because of course the world is always
fair to those who win
but my case is somewhat unusual this
sort of hybrid
lucky tragedy of losing my vision can
for the most part
be clearly pointed to as the cause of my
discovery of musical posing
and my eventual being up here but it was
an accident
if it wasn't for that misstep on the
ladder none of this would have happened
for me
and i think far more often than we'd
like to admit we are all pushed and
pulled by accidents equally as
significant as mine
but far less obvious or apparent if at
all
we are rarely aware of or accounting for
the good or bad luck in our stories
because it's never really something we
do or see i've obviously thought a lot
about this
and i realized that bad luck isn't just
what happens to us
but also what doesn't and we never know
about it
and likewise so is good luck so in that
sense i would say yes
in some strange way i am lucky and luck
does play a big role in one success
but at the same time the ability to do
this to be a successful music composer
was inside me the whole time the
potential energy of my success and skill
was just sitting there
waiting to be made kinetic by the random
variables of the world
and my personal circumstances and so
it's really both luck and skill i would
say
because of course no one ever succeeds
in anything hard by not trying
not having talent and not working hard
one has to have all of those and have
them in order
to have any shot at all but plenty of
people who work hard
have talent and try their best never
succeed in any grand thing
luck only finds those who work hard and
or are talented
but it doesn't find all those who are or
do and i think this is important to
realize because
if i'm in large part to credit my being
here tonight to the arbitrary
circumstances of my accident
then how can i have been totally and
personally to blame for not having been
here before my accident
or if my accident never occurred in
truth the majority of us are going to
live an ordinary life
never knowing precisely where the good
and bad luck lurks
but having been blind for the second
half of my life now it is clear to me
that an ordinary healthy life
is just as noble and worthwhile work
hard
try your best and enjoy the good fortune
if it comes your way
but don't depend on it and don't think
if it doesn't
you are somehow less worthy or solely to
blame
i see that now felix gestured with a
slight head nod to the crowd to indicate
that now he was finished
thank you so much for watching for
anyone interested there is now a brand
new line of pursuit of wonder merch
available on pursuitofwonder.com this
line includes a hoodie
a crew neck and a long sleeve tee
featuring a realist approach to our
classic brain blender tee
additionally two poster collections
inspired by the original artwork and
ideas featured on the pursuit of wonder
instagram
are now also available again if you're
interested you can find
everything new and previously existing
at pursuitofwonder.com
or by clicking the link in the
description below if you like any of the
items and do choose to purchase anything
thank you sincerely in advance the
support means a great deal
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you
next video